they say having connections is the
easiest way to make it in the film
industry
and they're not wrong we're about to
reveal
surprising famous actors who landed
cameos for their family members in major
projects
can you guess how many of chris
hemsworth's relatives have made
appearances
in marvel movies hint it's more than one
team thor of course tom holland isn't
the only talented one in his family
his recent movie cherry that hit the
scene back in january 2021 features
another holland
at least for a few seconds did you spot
him
tom's brother harry holland made a cameo
as the shaky kid
and was the one dealing illegal
substances that isn't the end of the
road for harry's cameos either
tom revealed he'll be making a comeback
as the shaky kid
in spider-man no way home listen to how
fun their time filming on set was
it's a funny scene though and it was
really fun for me to get to share that
moment with him i'm sure my mum and dad
will be very proud
you know what's even more wild than
harry's cameos
how much these two look like one another
i mean they honestly could be twins
and this would be the first spider-man
movie with two hollands in it
wonder woman is well wonderful
no surprise there considering she's
played by the iconic gal gadot
but who does gal use as her motivation
for this superhero story
her family of course that's why it was
only natural for her husband and two
daughters to have a cameo in wonder
woman 1984.
just listen to her gush and to have them
captured in the film with me
because they are part of it
mental life all three of them can be
seen at the very end of the film
her oldest daughter alma is having a
snowball fight with a little boy who
actually happens to be the director
patty jenkins son
and her husband and younger daughter
maya can be seen on the merry-go-round
it's a family affair and it's an amazing
amazing
souvenir that we will forever cherish
jennifer lawrence had not won but two
family members make a cameo in
mockingjay part 2.
honestly these might be the two most
important appearances
on this list without them we wouldn't
have the everlark end game we
love that's right jennifer lawrence's
two nephews played peta and katniss's
children
in the film's final scene want to know
what's even more adorable
the hug between their son and peta
wasn't scripted
it was just jen's nephew fooling around
with josh hutcherson
and even better yet jen totally pulled a
tom holland and spoiled her nephew's
appearances at comic-con
look at how shocked she was and josh was
playing with my nephew
chris hemsworth as thor roaming the
streets of modern day america
never gets old especially when fans
approach him asking for photos and
autographs
that's something chris can probably
relate to except in thor ragnarok it was
his cousin asking for a photo
yup chris managed to score his cousin
taylor hemsworth a whole line in his
film
honestly it was probably one of the best
lines in the whole movie
sorry to hear that jane dumped you ouch
from his own cousin
she didn't dump me you know i dumped her
of course the former king of wakanda and
black panther would have perks
we'd expect nothing less but we were
still shocked to find out that the actor
who played young chaka in the film
was actually related to actor john
connie remember this scene
that's john's son atandwakani well that
explains why we thought it was the
perfect casting
he truly is the closest thing to a young
version of chaka
have i ever failed you
they say your parents are your number
one supporters
so there's only one way to thank them
when you're an actor
have them make cameos in your projects
at least that's what benedict
cumberbatch did
both his mom and dad played sherlock's
parents in the sherlock season 4 finale
of course there could be no better
casting more than that the experience
meant
everything to benedict he said i'm so
proud of them and i'm so proud of the
reaction they got
and i think they're perfect casting as
my parents hmm
we wonder why they're so perfect
i can't tell you how glad we are
sherlock all that time people thinking
the worst
angelina didn't intentionally set out to
get one of her relatives on a movie set
it just kind of happened while she was
filming maleficent they were struggling
to find a little girl to play young
aurora who wasn't absolutely terrified
of the whole maleficent getup
you guessed it the only one who wasn't
running away screaming
was her daughter vivian just look at how
adorable it was to watch angelina
pretend like it was a game for her
no matter how perfect that scene turned
out in the final cut
angelina isn't too keen on pushing her
kids into showbiz
we didn't want her to be in a film don't
know want to push our children to be
actors
vivian wasn't the only jolie pitt to hit
the big screen
remember brad pitt's heartbreaking movie
the curious case of benjamin button
their child shiloh jolie pitt was the
star in this one
at least for a few seconds where they
appear as the young version of brad's
on-screen daughter caroline
but just like vivian shiloh hasn't
really made it back to the big screen
except for a little voice overall in
kung fu panda 3.
hi i'm
robert downey jr rdj an actual legend
and not
only because we're still not over tony
stark in fact rdj has been a star in
movies
other than the ones included in the
marvel cinematic universe
his film kiss kiss bang bang back in
2005 was a huge hit
maybe that's why he couldn't help but
get his son indio falconer a cameo in it
he played a young version of rdj's
character harry
take a look
so the cameo is cool and all but can we
talk about how awesome his name is
indio falconer there has to be a story
behind that
turn my mic up thank you
in our opinion hellboy is totally
underrated
who doesn't love seeing ron perlman in
action as hellboy
well this reporter in hellboy 2 got the
entire hellboy experience when she was
on set that day
she was the front and center of all the
action but
that could just be because she's
hellboy's daughter or ron perlman's
daughter to be more specific
her real name is blake pearlman
hollywood can do that
there's no denying how talented james
mcavoy is
i mean who else could play a better
professor charles xavier than him
but in his film filth we actually got
double the mcavoy
his sister joy mcavoy actually had a
part in the film as a character named
estelle
and to be honest with you i just got fed
up with people going what's he saying
you're probably wondering how chris
hemsworth got another spot on this list
and the truth is he's got a big family
remember in thor ragnarok when thor is
watching the play being put on
recreating loki's demise
well the fake thor isn't really all that
fake
it's chris's brother nope not liam
hemsworth
but luke hemsworth their oldest sibling
no wonder there's so much resemblance
no dakota fanning was a star in
hollywood before she could even start
high school
her acting skills are impeccable and it
seems to run in the family because her
little sister elle fanning is a disney
princess
literally she plays aurora in maleficent
however
before l could be the star of her own
film she made cameos in her sisters
dakota starred in the film i am sam as
lucy
and l played the younger version of lucy
you can catch a glimpse of her in this
scene
daddy this mustard we all know hannah
montana was a family affair
but how much of a family affair was it
we had miley cyrus starring alongside
her father billy ray cyrus but the show
also included another cyrus miley's
little sister noah
noah isn't so little anymore she's now
in the music industry herself but before
that she had multiple cameos as a little
girl in different hannah montana
episodes
how do you think miley liked having her
little sister tag along with her on set
having a little sister following you to
work doesn't sound like the most
peaceful experience
but the two sisters seem closer than
ever today being on stage with noah was
fun we played with water guns we kind of
sang together
we all know willow smith as the singer
of the hit song i whip my hair back and
forth but she also had an acting role in
her mother's movie madagascar escape to
africa
she was the voice behind the young
version of everyone's favorite hippo
gloria
take a listen well i think he's kind of
cute i think he's kind of a show-off
some of these family members went on to
land major roles like el fanning and
willow smith
while others like robert downey jr's son
only have
one credit to their name but no matter
what happened after these cameos you
have to admit that the experience of
filming must have been
so cool it had us wishing we had family
in the film biz
what cameo surprised you the most